[Music]
it's nine o'clock this is sky news
welcome to the show where i interview
people who have something to say about
the world today and how it's changing
they'll be from politics sport business
entertainment public life or they'll be
everyday people caught up in the events
of our times i'll be putting my
questions to tonight's special guests
[Music]
good evening the war in ukraine has
brought devastation across the country
whole towns have been flattened
thousands of civilians killed and
battles raging but could there be a
glimmer of hope on the horizon
negotiations this week led to russia
saying it will pull back on attacks on
the capital kiev
one man has been on the front line
protecting his city vitali klitschko he
was once a heavyweight world boxing
champion now he's mayor of kiev and he
has the fight of his life on his hands
he's speaking to me tonight
there's the war of bombs and bullets and
then there's a shadow war of spies lies
and information
one of britain's spymasters the head of
gchq says putin isn't being told the
truth by his security chiefs but who can
we believe i'll be putting those
questions to christopher steele former
british intelligence officer author of
that infamous dossier on donald trump he
has spent his life observing the comings
and goings of russian spies so he should
know what's going on whether he'll tell
us we'll see
also tonight in 2020 the discovery of a
terrifying new virus changed the world
as we know it
cities and countries went into lockdowns
but little more than a year later there
were vaccines available it was a truly
stunning achievement led in britain by a
businesswoman none of us had heard of
before but we know her now it's kate
bingham i'll be asking her how it all
unfolded and whether we're prepared for
the next one
let's get straight into our first
interview tonight vitale klitschko first
made his name as a champion boxer he
turned to politics in 2005 and became
the mayor of the ukrainian capital kiev
in 2014 but he never imagined he'd be
defending his city and his people from
an invasion by the russian military a
little earlier i spoke to vitaly
klitschko the mayor of kiev
vitale first up thank you so much for
sparing some time to talk to us when you
are
in the middle of what you're in
let me start with the military situation
now in kiev putin has advanced on the
city but he's failed to capture it and
nor has he at the moment sought to
flatten it
with shelling and moscow's now saying it
doesn't want to put kiev at military
risk
are we at a stage yet where you feel you
could say that keeve is safe
first of all
nobody feel him
safe
in ukraine
if you in ukraine are you sorry in
danger second point
right now the
huge battle we're talking right now and
listen it's uh explosion explosion uh
it's battle right now north of the city
and east of the city so you can hear
that now
outside
yeah i hear right now outside this
explosion
explosion because in
[Music]
europe
uh
baradian
right now right now there is fighting
it's
near to bravery it's a small city
satellite city
of
kiev
and that's why right now that circle
around uh the the the
russian russian uh army will move back
and uh they moved
uh but uh still danger and we listen
all day the explosions vitaly when the
russians say then that they tell us and
we hear these press conferences where
they say that they are switching
attention away from keeve
and they are moving their forces
elsewhere
you don't see evidence of that you don't
believe that's what they're doing
please don't believe russians
this will be biggest mistake
they told it's not we are in the next
lugansis was not true they told they
don't want to work
against ukraine it's not rude right now
right now the occupation of ukraine the
russian
russian forces uh make
war it's not rude right now it's
russians told they go away
it's not true the battle is there maybe
some part of um
forces move to another
side of ukraine but they still around
kiev and vitali i think we've got some
pictures i want to show you some
pictures that we've been seeing here in
the uk i don't know if you can see them
we have one of mario paul this is mario
paul this is from a drone
and then we also have some pictures from
urpin which is not that far
from you when you see these pictures
how does it make you feel
it's
it's painful to see these pictures the
city doesn't exist anymore
the whole
building is destroyed the city is
destroyed and
it was couple of months ago it's a great
part of our cities we're
very comfortable life and
it was privileged to live in a
satellite city to near to kiev right now
the the city not exist anymore right now
we're collecting their their bodies the
people who
uh killed from russians tarly when you
when you see those pictures of of of
other parts of ukraine
are you fearful that this could happen
to kiev or do you think that the
russians would not dare
uh to bomb the capital in that way
i have a feeling
i have a feeling the russians doesn't
have
some
some
moral protection or i don't know it's
they killing civilian
they
kill children women's
they destroyed mariupa
destroyed more than 50 percent of
buildings in harkid totally destroyed
its apartments building they destroyed
help of turning if it's
150 kilometers around 100 miles from
kiev and
i guess they can't use any
weapons we
talking right now
about the chemical weapons the russians
already use that in syria
and uh
eve couple of months ago
somebody tell me is
what i think about the war i will be
i i never expect
in the modern time
in europe
we have
huge war
this war is biggest one after the second
world war
and uh
if couple of months ago i tell it's
impossible
but right now
right now
right now if you if you ask about our
hometown
it's everything possible if we look on
marieupoli hurricane
just on on life in kiev at the moment
it's hard for us to understand what it's
like there because what we see
is the reports focused on war can you
describe what it's like in kiev at the
moment are you
able to go to shops are cafes open kids
go into schools how are you living at
the moment
before the
before the war just two months ago
one half months ago the population of
our city
uh what three and a half million people
we are one of the largest city in east
uh europe
right now we guess is uh health
population is
women's children already left
the majority right now the mans who
ready to defend
our city yeah uh
the life
we it's actually it's a war destroyed
the logistic uh war destroyed the normal
life in the people
and uh right now the the streets is
empty it's uh blog post with web with
people uh with uniform
with weapons spiritual defense
but uh slowly uh listen uh ukrainian
listen the russian forces a little bit
far from keith but everybody want to get
we want to come back to city
it's personal
it's uh i talk to many people everybody
won't come to bed but it's personal
decision of every families for everyone
but the
it's personal risk for everyone who come
to kiev we see we have a release an
explosion
uh
every day
and
the risk
to diet is pretty high and that's why my
personal advice for everyone
who want to come please
take a little bit more time
let's see how
situation will be developed in the next
couple of weeks and vitali your family
you have children you've got three
children
do you see them or have you had to send
them away i mean presumably you are at
risk personally because the russians
have you on their hit list
minor brothers to give vladimir together
with me yeah
it's uh
i send my mom and vladimir and his
daughter outside of the countries right
now is
family it's outside of the country so
you haven't seen
you haven't seen your family for weeks
more than once that's really hard that's
really hard
um
you are on the russia hit list
president zielenski we know about
assassination attempts on him have there
been assassination attempts on you
everyone in ukraine
in danger
everyone every citizens of ukraine right
now in ukraine
her risk
i come from a military family
my father
former officer
uh he's actually
died
and spent his life to defend the people
in ukraine
in
by chernobyl uh
nuclear
catastrophe what ukraine have 1986
uh father study me and my brother is big
privilege
i am former soldier also
it's big privilege
for every man
to give his life
as defender of your country
and that's why we are not afraid
nobody wants to die
but
it's our home
it's our hometown
it's our families it's our children we
defend our children we defend the future
we don't want to live in the country in
in soviet union we don't want back to
ussr we don't want to live in the
country with no human rights waste no
press freedom waste no rules by talking
about the russian federation because
they put in the goal of putin to rebuild
russian empire and
to occupy ukraine and
to to rebuild soviet union
we was in susa and we don't back in the
past time and vitali you are clearly
prepared to die for your country i think
you're saying to me if you lose your
life
you are not afraid
nobody wants to die
nobody wants to die
i tell you some example
i
trying the every day i go to
every districts of our city i stumbling
by blog post and civil defense
i am very surprised the people with very
peaceful profession
for example musicians
actors
doctors
right now
they stay with uniform they never they
never expect to take the weapons in the
hands but right now they want to defend
his city
hometown
and
we
we always was peaceful nation
is we ukraine is peaceful country we
never was aggressive to anyone but right
now
is the question about our future future
of our children
can i ask you just quickly about your
future putin clearly wants to take the
donbass region and some of the south of
the country
could you live with russia taking some
territory from ukraine in order for
peace
russians right now starting to talk
about some compromise
what about we talk i don't know
uh compromise to give the russians uh
some part of our territory his
compromise
his job
uh the compromise if the russians killed
thousands of ukrainians and right now we
have to find the solution i don't know
what
we talk about what we what we have to
talk about
and that's why
that way just one wish
russians go away russian soldiers have
to go away from our home country and
after that we're ready to discuss
we understand the russian uh army much
stronger than ukrainian it's actually
ukrainian soldier ukrainian army
destroyed
meters
about
strongest russian strongest army in the
world
i explain why
ukrainians are tough because russian
soldiers paid their fighting for the
money
ukrainian soldiers ukrainian citizens
fighting for the future of our children
are you feel the difference between the
money
and the children
and vitaly i have one final question for
you then you're clear that you are not
going to
let putin take any ukraine territory
what about president selensky's
suggestion
that ukraine could perhaps
have a compromise at committing to
neutrality and maybe putting that to
referendum to the people is that
something as the leader of the capital
you could live with
uh first of all i'm not involved in
negotiation process between ukraine and
russia
second point
we doesn't have
the final document
that's why we don't know what we talk
about i i'm i'm not ready to give the
commenter about that
and
also the referendum
natural status we was always natural
country
we want to be the part of european
family it's our decision we want to be
democratic modern country it's our
decision
and to take away our wish
it's not fair it's we decide and we have
we need to be
someone who
take a decision regarding regarding
negotiation and referendum i don't know
how we make the referendum in in the war
big part of ukrainian right now outside
of the country they
moved
uh they to safety place
uh in during the war we have a lot of
question and not so many answers for
that
by the way
i'm
let's see the negotiation
document the
let's see
negotiation letters what uh
what make here
both sides enough that we can discuss
about it okay vitaly klitschko thank you
so much for spending some time to talk
to us tonight thank you
thank you
vitaly klitschko there while coming up
after the break we'll get the thoughts
from a former spy christopher steele
[Music]
um the cell aid which i have here in my
hands is the world's first
handheld
miniaturized and very ultra low cost
defibrillator
and this is being designed from the very
beginning to be easy to use
and affordable and we hope that it's
going to address the barriers that we
have right now to making these available
in public
so the device has been miniaturized so
that
it works to provide a small electrical
shock to the chest of someone whose
heart has stopped to restart the heart
again
the new design has
has removed all the unnecessary
components and made it small enough for
you to put in your bag or have in your
home and have it easily used without any
medical training whatsoever
as you can see in the in the video it's
meant to be snapped in half and the two
halves of the device are actually the
pads that stick on the chest of the
cardiac arrest victim
i was at work at a local restaurant to
me so that was a big moment obviously in
my life and i'm just very fortunate that
there was a different layer on site at
my work at the time that could obviously
be used to save my life basically but a
device like this that's so readily
available will just increase the chances
of survival by 10 volt
these devices are available for pre-sale
today on cellaid.iocellaed.io
and the major innovation is that these
devices are available for a tenth of the
price of conventional aeds at 199 pounds
and we're hoping that that lower price
will remove barriers to getting these in
homes and in workplaces and available so
that more people who can have them close
to them and have them save a life when
this when this occurs in public
[Music]
[Applause]
i love my job because
i get to do something that is
contributing to a better future
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back the british intelligence
agencies have been watching russia
closely for decades and since the
ukraine war started they've got their
finger on the pulse of the kremlin or at
least that's what they want ours and the
russians to believe only last night the
head of the british intelligence agency
gchq said putin doesn't know what's
going on because his closest colleagues
aren't telling him the truth but is all
of this disinformation my next guest
says no christopher steele thinks
british spies do have a good idea of
what's going on in russia and ukraine
and he should know because for many
years he was one of them he joins me now
chris thanks so much for joining us on
the show before we start to talk about
all things kremlin let's kick off with
vitali klitschko and that interview you
just watched it what what did you make
of him
thank you for having me on the program
beth i'm delighted to be here
i think people like vitaly klitschko
will be remembered for decades if not
centuries
as the real heroes of this period of our
history
and of ukraine of course
and a remarkable man incredibly brave
living in a city which is under siege
which he's possibly being targeted for
assassination i think we absolutely have
to take our hat off to him he smiled and
didn't answer that question but you
think he would have been targeted for
assassination without doubt i think
originally when this operation was
underwear yes definitely
so a man that really is risking his life
uh every day um let's get on to
the kremlin and intelligence so jeremy
fleming the boss of the
gchq said putin has made a strategic
miscalculation he said this in a speech
last night launching this invasion he
said his advisers are afraid to tell him
the truth is that your assessment too
i think that's part of the problem that
you have in an authoritarian system
where there is definitely not a premium
on passing bad news and real news back
up to the leadership however i think
there's a more fundamental point here
which is that russia has always had bad
intent in terms of rebuilding its empire
and dominating its neighbors
and it's never had the capabilities to
match that
and i think this big mistake that
putin's made in this situation of all
the mistakes and there are many
is that he believed that russia had the
capability to fulfill its intents
towards
ukraine and it doesn't and and had an
ability to do that quickly and that
hasn't happened and i guess my next
question for you
is that that has clearly caused discord
in the kremlin the russian defense
minister vanished with heart problems
what's going on are they all fighting
each other
churchill once said that studying the
kremlin was like looking at bulldogs
fighting under a rug you couldn't quite
see what was going on but you could hear
the growling and the snarling and it is
very much like that and
one of the problems we've got in
assessing russia over the years is that
it's not an open society it is it is a
complex society the leadership is not
uniform it's not monolithic but it is
suppressed and the divisions are kept
behind the scenes
the fsb the russian intelligence
services though presumably they are
leaking information to the ukrainians is
that partly why the ukrainians are
fighting more effectively is that partly
why people like vitali or president
zielenski despite having
been on putin's hit list with
mercenaries in the capital that they're
still alive is that what's going on yeah
i think it's important to remember that
ukraine and russia are like england and
scotland or england and ireland and that
many russians are of ukrainian origin
and vice versa they're incredibly close
these people and therefore the site the
thought of destroying your cousin's uh
house and home and cities and after all
kiev was the first capital of the
russian state is pretty horrendous to a
lot of russians and i suspect loyalty in
that situation is very complex and
difficult
today you the uk's military chief said
that while he expects the coming weeks
to be difficult that in many ways putin
has lost do you agree with that
assessment
yes i don't see there's a way back for
putin and i think this is one of the big
problems that the west is going to face
going forward i don't see how we can
trust putin in any sort of peace deal
that comes now and i don't see how we
can deal with him in terms of normal
business going forward after all the
president of america has called him a
war criminal
if you can't trust putin though in any
peace deal how does it end because
presumably it has to end with some sort
of deal i mean zelensky's talking about
neutrality
and a referendum i mean
how does it end if you can't trust
anything he does and you can't negotiate
i think it does end in a deal of some
sort
but i think that that deal is some way
off and i think it probably doesn't
include vladimir putin um what do you
mean by that chris well i think he he
may well be pushed aside out of the top
leadership or
even possibly assassinated by his own
people
the the point is that that we've gone
over a watershed here i don't believe
there's any way back for putin i can't
believe he can be rehabilitated in the
international community and that's a big
problem for us going forward it also
means he has no incentives to stop
fighting
i think that's true unless of course
they start losing on the ground and one
of the remarkable things about this
situation now is it does look as though
the russian army at least in some areas
is being defeated
and just finally on this
um
tony radekin has said putin failed to
anticipate the unity and cohesion
amongst free nations of the world
are you worried that this western unity
would crack if donald trump returned to
power
in the u.s well that's not an immediate
prospect
actually in this situation as at least
another two to three years before
there's a presidential election in
america it certainly wouldn't help i
mean whatever one thinks of trump he was
much more of an isolationist than other
u.s presidents he questioned nato's
existence and and solidarity and the eu
and all the institutions that stand up
to russia would were put into question
by him
and chris you're a russian expert you've
studied and gathered intelligence on the
kremlin for many years you now run a
private business doing something similar
were you surprised when putin invaded
ukraine
i was surprised at the scale of the
invasion i wasn't surprised that there
was a military operation or a political
operation to recognize the breakaway
republics as independent
but i had calculated others are
calculated the logistics of this didn't
add up
but if you cannot keep down a population
of 43 million people using only 150 000
troops it doesn't work so poor
intelligence from the russians
i think poor advice i think poor
intelligence in terms of what i think
putin was being told which was that
parts of ukraine would welcome the
russian troops with open arms and there
was a shadow governance structure that
could be brought in to replace the
current government
and you said in your submission to the
2018 this is the intelligence and
security committee uh within parliament
that look at
matters of national security you said uh
that russia was becoming more aggressive
that it was moving from an authoritarian
to totalitarian state
and that uh
putin had to be tackled was the west
asleep at the wheel are we partly to
blame for this
yes we are very largely to blame for it
in my view some of which is perhaps
understandable after 9 11 for example
there was an attempt to draw putin into
an anti-islamist alliance anti-terrorist
alliance that failed but i think
subsequently to that the problem has
been that the west has been naive about
putin and very slow to react to his
rogue state type activity
and on the issue of
how the west has reacted to putin i want
to ask you a bit about the relationship
between the uk and russia
and about oligarchs and money russian
money in london
in the uk for years you were monitoring
russia and the misdeeds of its spies
like murdering people uh in the uk
and yet you also saw british politicians
and businessmen they go into parties and
holidaying with oligarchs
do you think that the establishment here
let themselves get seduced
absolutely i think there were two things
going on there one is a element of
naivety because many of the russians who
come to london are very urban very
convincing very sort of westernized
they don't represent the real russia if
you like there is a dark side to russia
which not many people understand sadly
i've been studying it for the last 20
years
but i also think in addition to that
russian money a wall of money that hit
london it wasn't just russian but it was
russian money first i think
sort of set up a lobby a group of
interests who
serviced this elite who the lawyers the
estate agents the pr firms and so on and
it became a pretty important part of our
economy and i suspect also in terms of
investment and so on particularly after
brexit and what have you when we were
looking for other forms of investment in
the country this golden visa scheme
which is now so controversial and in
retrospect was such a bad mistake grows
out of that problem
and there is one person that's
particularly being talked about lately
which is evgeny lebvedev you said an
interview with skye last october with
sky news it was curious mr johnson boris
johnson had enabled the son of a kgb
officer now it's important that i make
it clear lord levitate is a british
citizen has broken no laws has condemned
the war in ukraine and strongly denies
any insinuation he's sympathetic to the
russian government
but
his elevation to the laws has been
controversial would you like to see the
intelligent reports around the decision
to make him a lord and put him into the
house of lords
yes there's a parliamentary procedure
involved here which is quite complicated
and i do understand need for
confidentiality and so on but this is
such a controversial appointment and the
story out there is that it was against
the advice of the security services so i
think it's a pretty exceptional case and
there was a debate in parliament the
other day and i think probably the
outcome of that should be more
transparency about how this decision was
made
you have some experience would you think
that
that has credibility that the security
services would have been anxious
about
this appointment
i think any sort of family member of a
former kgb uh officer or a kgb agent and
actually
lebedev is not the only one there are
quite a few former kgb officers who are
quite prominent in britain and in
business here who need to be very
closely looked at and certainly it's
surprising to me that they've managed to
operate in the country's country in the
way that they have well it is now
changing of course with these huge
sanctions against a number of different
people and companies
can i now bring you just to the world of
spies
because
is it fair to say that people are right
not to trust intelligence sources it's
often disinformation you often use
anonymous sources
yet we're all expected to be reverential
about british intelligence do you accept
that you offer us no truth or proof in
anything you say i think that's an
exaggeration clearly intelligence work
is as much an art form as it is a
science and what you're trying to do in
intelligence work always is to
test out a piece of information
get it from different sources get it
from different types of sources i think
that actually the calling out of this
invasion by western intelligence has
been a remarkable operation and i think
that
the the decision to preempt to make
intelligence public in this situation to
preempt russian activity has
wrong-footed the kremlin quite a lot
that that was interesting wasn't it
because what happened was things like
the invasion the planning of it then you
know the threat of chemical weapons
what's happened is western leaders who
would typically keep that all private
have been shouting about it and making
it public what's the tactic of doing
that
it's the information warfare i mean the
reason that intelligence often isn't
made public is obviously because of the
need to protect sources and techniques
and every time you make a piece of
intelligence public you are taking
certain risks in that regard however in
this situation where you're dealing with
strategic threat the invasion of a
european country by russia the decision
was obviously taken that that risk was
worth taking and i think it's paid off
but it's fair to say as well that
british intelligence officers would also
deal in disinformation as russians would
right
it depends how what you're talking about
i mean if you're saying that we should
be
spreading this information to russian
troops on the battlefield in ukraine
probably yes if you're talking about
disinformation about our own society
obviously not
and chris how does this end you you've
said that you
think that putin there's no way back for
him that there would have to be some
sort of regime change
in russia although how that could happen
still pretty opaque
klitschko said in that interview
that he was worried or he warned europe
the rest of europe
uh that there is a danger that this tips
into a wider european
war
do you agree with that are you fearful
about that
yes i think
people talk in terms of this being like
munich in 1938 1939
it's probably equally
threatening in terms of 1914 where we
sort of slipped into war by various
mistakes and smaller countries provoking
bigger countries and so on so there's
always a risk that something like this
can spread and you know the polls are
very robust they've talked about having
ukrainian fighter aircraft uh in their
country or provided from their country
so it's very important that nato remains
united
everyone sticks to the same script
everyone sticks to the same rules about
this in order to prevent this conflict
spreading okay chris i've got more
questions for you but i have run out of
time as ever thank you so much uh for
joining us uh on the show well look stay
with us coming up next the former head
of the uk vaccine task force dame kate
bingham
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
i love my job because
i get to do something that is
contributing to a better future
[Music]
welcome back the pandemic changed our
world as we know it we were told by the
government time and again that the only
way out of some of the most draconian
restrictions ever seen in this country
during peace time was through a vaccine
my next guest was working as the head of
the uk vaccine task force in 2020
securing the jabs that was still in
development and setting up a plan that
would make the uk a leader in vaccine
roll out earlier i spoke to dame kate
dame kate your task doing the vaccine
task force was to source a vaccine
scale up capacity
build capability in vaccine development
then make for the provision of
international distribution and then
strengthen the uk's capability for
resilience for future pandemics which
actually sounds exhausting just reading
it all out
um there's so much to talk about about
that and also about
future proofing against pandemics but if
we kick off with
what you did in the vaccine task force
what was the single biggest lesson you
learned in that whole process
i mean the single biggest lesson was
probably getting the right team together
and having a clear mandate and
empowering the team to actually do the
work that we needed to do because
everything was in a rush because every
day we took more people were going to
die so
the first thing we did was to actually
put together the experts from industry
together with the experts from
government and agree this is the
strategy and this is how we're going to
do it and because there was so much
uncertainty what we did is put in place
a very uh focused um set of meetings
three times a week so that we at least
had a framework with which to actually
start
communicating what we were doing and
talking about progress so getting that
team together
uh getting a diverse team together
actually so we had plenty of women uh
who brought real depth of skills
alongside uh the men we had in the team
in terms of learning diversity of skills
people thinking backgrounds uh made for
a really effective team and without the
team this couldn't have happened now it
was a success it's transformed
everyone's lives that
the vaccine rollout worked and the
vaccine was found
but when you were contemplating this at
the beginning
did it occur to you that you were most
likely going to fail i knew it was most
likely to fail
and there were so many reasons why i was
likely to fail the first thing was that
we had no vaccine against any human
coronavirus so we had no template or
playbook to follow the second thing was
that vaccines historically take five to
ten years to develop the quickest was at
four years and that was done for 50
years ago
and we didn't know anything about this
new virus so we had so many reasons to
be skeptical that this was possible and
to be able to uh go from sequence to
start vaccinating people in a year
which is what we did was not what we
expected to do at the beginning because
we knew that most vaccines fail you're
obviously a very successful person was
there a moment you thought this is
kamikaze i'm setting myself up for
failure how did it come about that you
took the helm
the reason i was
asked was because patrick valance
had set up an expert advisory group to
advise the government on the procurement
and identification and procurement of
vaccines
and he then invited me to join that
advisory group and my job for the last
30 years has been to develop novel
drugs to treat unmet diseases and so
when patrick then asked me to join the
expert group i
asked him why since i don't know
anything about vaccines um and he said
but you understand the small company uh
landscape and it's that innovation
landscape which is actually where the
bulk of the vaccines have come from so
he brought you in because he knew you
from industry but then the prime
minister personally called you up
correct and asked you to do it
everything is done by text so you get a
text saying can you speak so i first got
a text from matt saying could i speak i
then spoke to him and he then said the
prime minister had asked him to ask me
to do it i then said i want 24 hours to
think about it and 24 hours later i went
back with a list of conditions on the
the basis of which i would do it and
having established that then pm called
me and that was to seal the deal then
really that was to basically accept the
conditions which was six months that i
reported to
the pm that i would have a quick
decision-making process
um that i could hire my own team to be
able to get on and do it i mean did you
have this phone you thought i am
i'm going to fact this is awful i've
been asked to do something i've got to
do because it's the pm's asking me in
the middle of a pandemic
and i don't know if i can do it so
absolutely i had that entire imposter
syndrome you know i can't do it and i'm
not the right person um and that was
because i've not a vaccine expert and
the d so but while i do therapeutics so
what i'm very familiar with is how do
you develop new drugs and in patients
but those are for patients
who have a disease putting something
into people who are healthy volunteers
is just a little bit different
prophylactic vaccines and so when i was
called
i hooked on the vaccine as being this is
what they're wanting me for but actually
they're not what they want is someone
who can do basically what venture
capitalists do which is put teams
together build plans uh figure out
milestone based
events which you which are key to
actually the success of the development
of of the
whether it's the therapeutic or a
vaccine um and so there's lots of the
style of how venture capitalists work is
what was needed here and the venture
capitalist mindset
and then whitehall
they're kind of different culturally
different very different things
you presumably met quite a lot of
resistance that's my first question then
my second question on this is that
is the venture capitalist mindset only
applicable in
the public sector when it's an emergency
situation
so two questions on the did i meet
resistance not really is the answer so i
had
absolute support and cooperation from
the pm and actually if you've got that
top level
leadership it is incredibly helpful
right and i established upfront that we
were going to be putting
money at risk without knowing if any of
these vaccines would work so it's what
the what the um whitehall calls no
regrets funding and so we've established
the principle that if we wanted a
vaccine we were going to have to put
money up front there was a lot of
scrutiny around you the fact that you
were married to a treasury minister you
know you know there's all these sorts of
this charge about being part of the
chamocracy if you like and there you are
doing this incredibly hard job uh
for and not being paid to do it did you
ever have moments when that happened
thinking i've put myself i've been asked
to do i've stepped up to do it and now
i'm being publicly criticized you didn't
really have a right of reply did you
just sometimes say why have i bothered
like why the hell am i doing it did it
annoy you of course it annoyed me um
the challenge is um this all happened um
just only a few weeks before i was due
to finish and by then we'd put it all in
place had all that happened early on
um it might well we might well have
ended up in a different place but you
might have walked you mean
oh it just may not we never would have
achieved what we achieved the advice i
got um was incredibly clear which is
take your ego out of this focus on what
you're doing and and move on because
this will all pass over and it did yeah
of course it did
it's very bizarre when you when you're
not used to being in that world to have
a whole lot of people say a whole lot of
lies about you and you can't respond
i mean it's really bizarre lily allen
has a great song and so i used to go uh
running
in the dark with a head torch on
listening to lily allen and it was great
and i'm not going to say the name of the
song in people i'd be off to guess it
yeah
i watched your romana's lecture you gave
it in oxford in 2021
and you spoke about how your father your
late father lord bingham
had been honored given that lecture
19 was it 19 years before you gave yours
or 18 it was one of the other
and and you talked about
you you spoke about how he talked about
um the vulnerability of personal freedom
in times of crisis
and then i saw
you you paused um
and you you needed to kind of collect
yourself and use
when you spoke about your dad what was
what was in your mind at that moment um
i just i caught mum's eye who was
sitting in the front row and you know
i'd practiced it and i'd said it so many
times so it wasn't as if i was saying it
for the first time but then seeing mum
sitting there that's what absolutely uh
triggered me so i don't have to say just
stop and it was actually i mean it was
actually a lovely moment you know
it wasn't absolutely but it was
unexpected for me but well incredible
that you followed your dad as well and
one mother question about him as i said
he was widely regarded as the greatest
lawyer of his generation one of the most
seniors justices in
the land and how how did he influence
you
your dad uh
not to go into the law
so i went and did i mean i was very keen
uh i think to carve my own path and
that's why i ended up in science so no
nobody else in my family does science uh
nobody else does sort of small business
e innovation risk that sort of thing so
i think i'm just a you know
a maverick
right let's quickly get on to future
pandemics covered is it over what we
know is we are we had delta um variant
that was really very serious last year
we're now in the middle of omicron
this could continue to
evolve um an outcome you know new
variants could out compete the question
is will it ultimately end up as a
seasonal flu type disease and we hope
that is where it will end up so that
there's sufficient levels of immunity
that we won't have this well kate i mean
patrick balance when i've gone to the
press conferences he has talked about
this transition from pandemic to endemic
yeah or epidemic endemic endemic um
where it does become like the seasonal
flu but you you say it's still not clear
i don't think it's quite there yet right
um and
and so to the extent i mean the stat we
had this morning was ten percent of
of children in the uk
have coveted right now so that is still
a vast level of uh viral transmission
and presence in in the country so we
just don't know yet what the remaining
drift and mutations could be
is the government ready to scale up in
the way it did before
should another virus come along
that really threatens
the the public well a lot of the scale
up has been done so part of what our job
was in 2020 was to put those
plans in place so we
um
basically took the existing ecosystem
for vaccine manufacturing and scale up
and nine different sites around the
country we have now
uh funded to scale up into much more
significant
capability so we've got a lot more
capability here now you talked about
having someone in government that's
responsible for this yes i mean i think
we should be treating it like we treat
defence because you know we're much more
likely to get a another serious pandemic
than we are to be invaded by somebody
yes but really serious not just a
cabinet minister yeah absolutely and it
needs to be somebody
ideally um
uh that comes in i think that needs to
have that private sector experience if
you suggested that's the pm yeah of
course and what did he say oh they you
know they'll take all those suggestions
well ultimately
transpires i don't know do you think
that we have finally killed the
stereotype that science is a boy's
subject i mean there's a lot of very
very punchy women who were absolutely
instrumental in in the whole initial
covered response um no i don't and i
think it's partly because um we don't
uh teach our kids in school as to what
the what you can do in science so people
i still think think of scientists as
being you know men in white coats well
actually it's not that if you think
about what we're dealing with in
technology whether it's phone apps or
cyber security or how do you deal with
climate change and as soon as you start
seeing what all of those underpin
underpin by scientific understanding
actually that's what's going to get
people excited because these new you
know younger people now they absolutely
want to help um save the world do you
think it's a coincidence that the people
heavily involved in
this vaccine were women
i think women are very good at problem
solving and just getting on with it as
you did well look thank you so much
thanks kate for talking to me i
appreciate it pleasure thanks for having
me
well that's all for today's show thank
you to all our guests vitaly klitschko
christopher steele and dame kate bingham
and if you scan the qr code on your
screen right now you can listen to the
beth rigby interviews podcast a new
episode will be available later tonight
each week i take a look at the
highlights of the interviews and there's
some extra behind the bits scenes start
setting too that's on the sky news app
or wherever you get your podcast
coming up on sky news at 10 a special
report from urpin by our special
correspondent alex crawford
[Music]
[Music]
you